I think one of the things that uh
inspires me most about you is that you
keep
um
you keep re I don't say Reinventing
yourself but you keep coming back with
like new growth on the tree you keep
coming back with something else to offer
and that's very inspiring to me and I'm
wondering if like hearing these old
songs does that does that inspire you in
any way like
well these songs got to me when I first
heard them when I was just a kid so that
and I never forgot bobolina I never
forgot that I was just going
okay that's out there that exists and
you can go there anytime
that you're ready to yes you know and
and uh you got to be with the right
people and got to be everything's got to
be right then you can get there and I I
just love that kind of music and uh but
it's it's so radically different from my
other music uh that I'm uh
sometimes uh people can't go
they can't go both places right and
that's you know well you've done you
know it's like we talked about this once
before but it Bears repeating that I was
in the as I was in studio 8h when you
did Keep On Rocking The Free World as
was Jim and uh I tell anybody tell me
anybody uh because uh Lauren Michaels as
is saying television is the worst way to
experience music and I think he's
usually right except
um you and the guys did something happen
that night something was good yeah
something was not just good was
Transcendent and punched through the
television and uh I thought well okay
I'm on the floor at 8h I'm a kid I'm in
my 20s I'm watching you
do that and the place you just melted it
you just I think there was structural
damage to 30 Rock
uh and it's never been quite repaired
um and I was blown away by that
performance
and then go online and find out that
people who weren't there who just saw it
on TV feel the same way so when it it
did punch through yeah it did punch
through yeah I remembered that I I you
can't tell
when that's going to happen but it was
very focused the band was very good and
everyone was establishing themselves in
a relationship with each other this was
four guys who've never played together I
played with Pancho and Crazy Horse but
Steve and uh and uh Charlie had never
played with they played with each other
but they never played with us
and God though it was just so uh good
and then we got in the studio we played
a couple of times then when we went
somehow when we got to uh Broadway video
and we had our own dressing room
then uh
they completely dismantled the dressing
room between Pancho and Steve and
Charlie it completely it was you know
and then the staff came in and they were
looked at it and I was like what you
know what the hell is going on here I
mean they were they couldn't believe it
but to these it was like a rock and roll
myth you know you crack you trash your
dressing room yeah okay yeah it's the
key so these guys trash this dressing
room yeah and I'm going okay well that's
a rock and roll that's that's a moment
but it seemed to be establishing itself
and no matter where we went uh at those
kind of things kept happening like we
were supposed to run down Rocking In The
Free World for the Run for the run
through and we did up instead
yeah
and didn't didn't tell anybody we just
did that because you didn't want to you
didn't want to spend that no coin on the
rehearsal show no but the up
that we did is really good too yeah that
was a good one I think we have that but
I mean I don't think you that's
interesting because I don't think you
that
to do it to do keep on rocking at the
dress rehearsal
you might not have been able to get
there for forever there is no rehearsal
you know so we threw a song away that
wasn't going to be in the study and
didn't tell them what's going to be so
we didn't we didn't sacrifice it yeah
just uh I didn't think NBC would be okay
with up
you sort of knew they wouldn't so we
figured it wasn't going to be something
yeah
it's a good thing you had that in your
back pocket yeah yeah that's a good one
for that I always think whenever uh if
someone ever puts a video camera in my
face if I'm on the street and starts to
ask me a question I don't want to answer
um I'll just start singing an
unclearable Song by Led Zeppelin
oh yeah
and be like look if you guys can clear
that you can go ahead and hear my
comments but I might do that if I'm ever
uh forced to testify in front of the
Senate
um there was so much goodness you've
brought so much more goodness into the
world world record uh is uh the new
album and I do love it and I do love how
optimistic
it is who is this on the cover that's my
dad is that your dad yeah
that's my dad good looking that's a good
looking serious man there's a serious
good-looking Dad it was a a writer and
uh he's writing for the Toronto Globe
and Mail at that time wow
did he approve of your musical
aspirations uh not quite as much as my
mom did yeah
my mom was totally supportive and got me
everything I would go to the wall to get
you know anything that I needed yep uh
and uh so I was able to uh make enough
money playing and then getting help from
her to get amplifiers and stuff like
that right right well I remember the big
thing between my mom and dad about who's
going to pay for this amp you know
you know he's got to have the amp my
mind your mom said wow you cannot not
have an amp you have to have you know so
I was looking at this I haven't paid
Echo to win and another
Fender tremolux or something and anyway
ultimately we got the amps
I feel like you would have gotten them
one way or the other we were we I knew
where they were
yeah you would case the joint